vous venez d'avoir un aperçu de la façon dont les
Américains ont vraiment de la nourriture, nous avons donné aux gens
une voix, nous avons donné la vérité aux gens ouais,
mais vos chansons, elles glorifient le
mode de vie des gangs, des armes à feu, de la drogue, notre art est le
reflet de notre réalité, ce que vous
me voyez, vous sortez  ta porte je sais ce que
je vois et un angle amarin tu reçois un cas
de cocaïne précipitée de Colombie
aucun de nous n'a de passeport donc je vais
vérifier la source prochaine question serez-
vous plus prudent sur ce que vous dites comment
vous dites oh  miel noix non hein la liberté d'
expression inclut la musique rap droit
exerçons-nous notre premier amendement en tant
qu'officier sur la route du gouvernement alors